i'm so interested to know what you guys
are going to think of this interview
you're about to hear i've been
increasingly trying to get some
legitimate experts and people who are
doing cool things on the show
not merely talking about the loser bozos
who want to steal your money today we're
talking to steve kirsch a man worth
probably more than all the gurus we've
ever talked about
combined he's a serial entrepreneur
who's made multiple exits and now he's
applying his problem solving to covet
19.
i think though even if you're jaded
about covet 19 you're kind of tired of
hearing of it i know sometimes
i am you still can get a lot from this
conversation because
fundamentally it's about problem solving
it's about
looking in places that other people
haven't and i know i walked away from
this interview simultaneously
more hopeful that a lot of opportunities
exist that could be
huge for the treatment of cover 19 but
also
a little bit more pessimistic that uh
our bureaucracies a lot of our
larger health organizations are going to
be the ones that find it or fund it
so guys i think this will be fascinating
for those of you who
stayed at the end and uh i wanted to
hear what you guys think so sit back
it's gonna be a long watch grab some
coffee grab some popcorn grab whatever
you need to grab
and enjoy welcome to coffeezilla today
we have perhaps
the first real guru i've ever spoken to
um
we talked to a lot of fraudsters
scammers
on this channel and it's a nice
exception today we have steve kirsch
steve you have a bs and a uh
ms from mit with in electrical
engineering and compsci
you are which i found out recently the
inventor of the optical mouse
which uh thank you for that it makes all
of our life a lot easier
and in fact um you and i have a lot in
common
which is our mutual hatred of scams back
in the days that fax machines were huge
people were falling for these penny
stock scams
and you went after these guys who
visited a lot of money you eventually
even some of these people went to prison
that you went after so you're kind of
like you kind of did a version of the
coffeezilla thing before it was
oh yeah before was before we were
youtube yeah before youtube so
uh i love it but the reason you and i
first connected is actually over coveted
19
which you are now taking a swing at um
you started
cetf the covet 19 early treatment fund
which we're here to talk about today
so let me first just say thanks for
coming on the show i really appreciate
it sure michael my pleasure
i've been a big fan of your uh of your
videos i mean
i get these youtube get rich quick
things all the time
and so i'm always searching for okay so
what's behind these scams and so
your site you know naturally comes up
and i just love your exposes i mean
they're just awesome you know i love the
the latest dan lok
one you know with the dragon 100 and
and figuring out well he just repurposes
content
and so
no you have to be you have to be in the
seven or eight figures so
you know i qualify for the dragon 100
but but
dan has not reached out to me to invite
me
i don't understand why what a shame yeah
he
should actually get your number that is
incredible well i mean you
do you know dan maybe you can pass it on
and and i can have a conversation with
him and that would be actually fun
i have his phone number i'll give him a
call i'll make sure that he
is connected with you and we'll just
right yeah we'll get it all started
so let's talk about uh kova 19 because
i think your story is fascinating so
actually um i sort of have
an idea of maybe your motivations here
but
you can tell me if i'm wrong if i'm
right so early
like a long time ago back in 2007 you
were diagnosed with a rare
type of blood cancer incurable but
basically you had like five years to
live
or so you thought but you really
according to the research
you took your health into your own hands
and uh you got into some clinical trials
and
here you are 13 years later do you think
that this self-autonomy approach to
your own health is what led you to want
to pioneer new treatments of covid19
um well it's really self-preservation
to be honest right and so when i got
uh waldenstrom's it was you find the
best researcher and you
uh and you make sure that the
researchers are funded
and so for covet 19 that was a threat to
me because i have all of the risk
factors i have diabetes
i'm 65 uh
i have high blood pressure you know so
every single thing
that's a risk factor for covid is like
my mortality uh
or the fatality rate for someone with my
conditions
was very high so this is not like i'm
gonna go play social distancing
uh gamble this is like i'm in lockdown
until this is
uh resolved and so i had a very personal
interest
in just solving this for me and uh
you know the the fact that everybody in
my family
uh my friends and everybody else in the
world benefits
um you know that's a that's an extra
plus you know i like to call it
enlightened self-interest
where it works for me and it also works
for others so
so i basically put my business on hold i
delegated all the decisions to my
co-founder
and uh basically checked out of the
business
and started a 501c3 essentially to
raise funds and accept grant proposals
from scientists all over the world who
would have something that might be
interesting and useful
for covid in an early treatment
situation which means
you get it you give it to people right
after
they uh are diagnosed with
covid and so as the earlier you you
treat people the better
yeah no i and let's get into that
because your early treatment fund is
sort of philosophically
different from a lot of research that's
going on right now which is primarily
focused on
late stage therapies people who are on
ventilators that's a lot of the
you know clinical trials that are being
done can you and
and also people are focused primarily on
vaccines which you're not focused on
can you explain your approach for people
why you're looking at this early
treatment thing
rather than these late states let's say
people as on
on their death bed sure because in any
virus they're basically
there are two ways you approach it um
you either
prevent it with a vaccine or you treat
it with an antiviral
and if you have to um treat with an ant
if in this case we're not going to have
a vaccine until
next year or sometime if you know at the
earliest
just because it takes so long to go
through these trials and so forth
and but if we had a treatment we could
actually do
challenge trials on these vaccines right
so you could take
give someone the vaccine and then you
can give them
covet now you can't do that now
ethically because we don't have a
treatment that that's effective
right so you you could end up killing
people you can't do those challenge
trials but if you had something that
works then you can actually accelerate
dramatically the time
to a vaccine because what happens in a
vaccine
is you give it to tens of thousands of
people and you
assume that some small percentage like
one percent or whatever
are going to get coveted and are going
to get sick
and so you have to then you know it's
just a game of
very very uh you're looking for a very
small effect in very large numbers
whereas if you can actually challenge
them with the virus
it becomes much faster but you can only
do that once you have a treatment
so that's one of the reasons it helps
accelerate
the vaccine but the other reason of
course is that half the people in
america aren't going to take a vaccine
i'd love to talk about that a while for
people to
even if we had a vaccine it's going to
take a while to inoculate you know 6
billion people
and so and it doesn't viruses and
vaccines are never 100 in people
right you know the best or 99 and
you know for um for some of these
diseases
um uh there's you know it's like 20
effectiveness for the vaccine so we
don't know how effective it's going to
be
for people who are obese the uh the
vaccine may be
a lot less effective and so forth so
it's critical that we have a treatment
and
if we can find a drug that's on the
shelf that's already approved drug
that reduces the either the
hospitalization rate and or
fatality rates from covid that's a huge
win and it's so inexpensive it's 20
million dollars to do
all of the drugs that have been applied
to what are fund
you know so that's less than the cost of
one study that was funded by
like barda funded a study to study one
drug it was 20 million dollars for one
study
for that 20 million we could have tested
every single drug that's applied to us
and we've only been able to raise like
three million dollars it's a
it is really a shame because this is the
fastest
and is the least expensive way um
to combat covid and and i can i can
virtually guarantee that we are going to
find something
that is going to be transformative for
this disease and it will have been
on the shelf the whole time and it was
just because we are not
taking our um the money and putting it
in the right place we're not investing
efficiently effectively to um
to solve this disease yeah let's talk
there's
several things there i want to touch on
we'll touch on repurposing in a second
but
i definitely want to hit on the fact
that vaccines
are almost certainly not going to be the
silver bullet that solves this pandemic
overnight
even if we had one today because as you
rightly pointed out
a lot of americans are going to refuse
to take the vaccine
so almost from the outset we need to be
exploring other options and that's what
you're doing right you're pushing
for anti-virals now you're going towards
a uh a method called repurposing drugs
rather than trying to make them from
scratch
can you talk about why you want to go
with that approach
sure because if you make a custom drug
for a specific virus that can take
uh many many years three four five years
and cost hundreds of millions of dollars
i'm able to raise you know two million
three million dollars so
that that kind of money is just out of
the question and so the only
option available to us is drug
repurposing and that's really fast
because the drugs have already been
approved and it works about 10 percent
of the time in 10 percent of the
diseases it's worked previously in
viruses in fact where you have a
repurposed drug so
azt for example for aids it wasn't the
best treatment available the custom
drugs that came on later were much
better in fact azt could be
uh you know some people would say that
well that was worse than the
then than the disease the cure was worse
than the disease but the point is that
there was a repurposed drug there
for ebola we had remdissevier and for
covet we have remdi severe
uh but it's has a very small effect
because remdissevere is being given
way too late uh to people to make a
difference it's like
you're throwing a life prison you have a
life preserver on the boat
and there are two people in the water
you have one life preserver two people
in the water
one guy is five feet under water and
he's on the right side of the ship and
the other guy is at the surface
well of course you got to save the guy
who's about to go under
so you throw your one life preserver to
the guy who's five feet under he's never
able to reach it and you lose it
in other words we're doing that with
people on ventilators
we're not saving any lot we've proven
that we're not saving any lives with
remdissevere when it's given very late
we have we're shortening hospital stays
we're not saving any lives if we want to
save lives we should be
making giving remdissevier very early so
this is why the new
treatments um there the the gilead is
opening it will be opening up trials
of inhaled rem to severe which can then
can be given
at the first sign of of covet because
covered you know think of covet as like
a fire burning inside of you
by the time you have symptoms the fire
has spread to your entire body
and and so by then it's you're really
hard to control because these
the pills that you take the rem disavow
whatever that's like a small bucket of
water
and if your entire body is on fire it
becomes very hard to put out
but if you can give that bucket of water
very early
on then you have a much better chance of
extinguishing the fire
and so this is why early treatment is so
important it's like
you put out a forest fire when the
lightning first hits or do you let the
thing spread so it's a
you know it's a huge um you know and i
gotta
i i'm i'm in that situation right now
you know we have a fire that's that's
not too many
miles from my home um that is only
twenty percent contained so
you know that fire analogy is is very
close to home right now for me
literally literally literally
um i'm checking every day whether i'm uh
in uh
whether the evacuation zone warnings but
it appears
that we're getting lucky and it's under
control let me let me ask you this
so obviously uh you know early detection
is key with this whole approach now
a lot of people would say and i've had
personal friends who've had this
challenge
they get coveted they can't get a test
or if they do get a test
they don't get the results for two weeks
so i think
more uh cynical people among us would be
would be saying well that's
that's great steve but honestly we have
to work with what's pragmatic
and pragmatically people aren't finding
out they have covet until the fire
but that's verbally raging because the
abbot i think the avid test uh the
basically the five dollar do it at home
instant result
five minute test um i think it just got
some sort of approval
um if i recall correctly and so
you know those sorts of things are game
changers and so we can find out very
early and the other thing is you know
i've got this one of these auro rings
that i
bought for 300 bucks and i
take my temper and i look at and and you
wear this thing at night
and it measures your your temperature
over the entire night time
to be clear this is not a woo-woo thing
this is when when you first showed me
this and i heard aura i was thinking
like
like health auras and so i was like is
he about to show me something
no no no no no no no it's like you are a
it's a scientist
here let me let me take it let me show
you so this thing is uh
it's a super high tech ring and i you
can see the insides of it uh
here um and what it does
is at you wear it at night and it
measures among other things your body
temperature your heart rate variability
um and and stuff like that and
the the idea is that if you have
a virus the first uh
sign that you get typically in a virus
is a temperature rise
at night not during the daytime and so
this becomes a very sensitive way to
measure your temperature
at night so you can see oh do i have
covered because if i have
covid then i'm going to treat it like
instantly
with one of the drugs that we know to be
effective
and so that way many people at home know
about that i sure didn't know about it
before kind of talking to you
um is that the thing about when you get
a virus your temperature at night
increases that's pretty
that's pretty amazing yeah look i didn't
know about it either before i started
this but you know you talk
to enough virologists then they tell you
you know yeah i mean and you see this
you see a ucf study in
ucsf study with them and you say wow
what's this about
and then they start to tell you oh it's
temperature rise at night
at night really i always thought it was
temperature rise of the daytime
and so you learn these things in going
through this process that you didn't
learn before because nobody ever told
you
i think that's one of the really cool
things about what you've done which is
what exactly what you did with
your early kind of incurable bone cancer
story where you
really found these experts and kind of
picked their brains rather than just
relying merely on what maybe your doctor
told you that week
oh yeah yeah no you can't you you you
can't do that
so so tell me about what you've learned
from these
covid experts because you did the same
thing with covet you went and talked to
some of the coronavirus experts is that
right
you should always go to the guys who
were the best in the world
and so that's what i did is i talked to
virologists i said you know so
who was one of the best guys who can
convene
a panel of 11 or 12 experts so we can
review these things and we'll have
experts in the the clinic experts in
research
experts in transit translational experts
in
lung diseases experts in coronavirus and
so forth and so you have this
sort of 360 degree view
of of the disease and so this way we can
take the 40 grant applications that have
come into the website
and prioritize them triage them as
effectively and say
hey we're going to fund this one we're
going to fund this one and we're going
to fund this one
because you're using experts to
uh to do the triage and
and what what i found when i talked to
researchers is that the best researchers
in the world
were not being funded and this is like
holy crap we're spending trillions
on on mitigation but why
are we starving at the world's
best scientists and and arguably the
world's best scientist of all time is
bert vogelstein
okay he is the most cited scientist
of all time in any field
ever in the history of mankind
he couldn't get money for his study
where he showed an 80 percent
reduction in hospitalization rates based
on observational data
and he wanted to approve we wanted to
prove it in a
in a randomized controlled trial and he
needed over a million dollars to do that
he couldn't wait for funding from nih
and barda
and so forth and so he came to us and
applied and we said
sorry we're out of money that is
a tragedy and but he's not the only one
the point is that if you have the best
scientist of all time
and he can't raise money then how do you
think
the guys who are not the best scientists
of all time
are faring the answer is not
good either why are we struggling to get
money into these scientists hands i
thought that bill gates was spending
like
billions of dollars we hear all these
numbers no uh
where's that money going yup therapy
accelerated raised
raised 120 million dollars
great what they did is they spent 40
million dollars on hydroxychloroquine
almost 40 million dollars on
hydroxychloroquine and
we're going like are you kidding me
i mean we spent we spent a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars we spent 300
times
less we funded what we thought was the
best trial on this which was david
bolwer's study out of university of
minnesota
it got results uh you know about a month
or
or or so a little bit more than a month
maybe two months ago
and shortly thereafter the uh the fda re
revoked the eua behind roxy chloroquine
because
hey this was a very legitimate study
that wasn't criticized double-blind
placebo
um uh study and and it had enough
patience and it proved that there was no
effect and
yeah well we were the main funders of it
the nih didn't fund it
they turned them down so we put in 120
000
because not because we believed
hydroxychloroquine was a good thing
but to prevent other people from wasting
tens of millions
on doing these experiments you know like
the world health organization for
example they're just
waste they were wasting lots of money on
on something that's not that nobody i
mean
this even wasn't approved by my my
scientific advisory board because they
wouldn't have approved it because it has
no basis for
um for giving a grant but i said look
you know
i'll use my money to do this and
and i wrote them a check uh because we
wanted to prove
that hey this isn't effective let's
focus on other things
so what you're saying saying basically
there's only
deployed in efficiently it's crazy
it's it's unbelievably bad in terms of
the capital allocation of this
20 million dollars in the right hands
with the people like
on my scientific advisory board is is
totally would be totally game-changing
for this disease
and it's and i have gone off to
to billionaires and millionaires and
i've said look
give me a million dollars i guarantee
you if i don't find something that
reduces hospitalization
and or fatality rates by 75 or more i
will refund i will personally
refund you and you know what i get when
i send that off
is they hit delete
what now so i'm saying risk-free
charitable donation
it either works or i give you your money
back nobody does that
and and yet you give it to to i gave it
to
billionaire like a week ago he just hit
the lead on it why do you think that is
is it because they think that they
should go with some kind of
bureaucracy more like the who or like
bill and melinda
you're critiquing as basically you're
just saying they're just wasteful with
the money they don't know how to spend
the money
which is typically kind of true of
larger the
larger of an organization they're
spending it efficiently you just kind of
get inefficiencies
yeah i mean the you know people think
that the gates foundation that they must
be small and they must be nimble and
quick and so forth
and the reality is um is quite different
than that
right it's very it's very difficult to
get money
out of the gates foundation it's very
bureaucratic you know we've asked the
gates foundation for money
and say look you know here of the four
things we've invested in we got
signals on all four we need we have
another four that's on the table and we
can get signals and signals means that
nih is interested in pursuing it that
everything says this
is the um this is going to be
transformative that's what i mean by
signal so four we're four out of four we
asked them hey
could you give us like a million dollars
or can you give us anything at all
and you get nothing they they just
ignore you they say oh
so what what you know tell me about the
one you got a signal on
right i mean it's like it's not even uh
it's as if you can't even ask that
question
and so it's been enormously frustrating
uh to raise money even when i personally
guarantee
to refund it if we don't find something
that's still
mind-blowing i don't understand that
thousands of people are dying
from this i've got some good news for
you okay there's a lot of
self-proclaimed millionaires who watch
this channel okay
a lot of them dan lok watches this
channel
kevin david watches this channel i
shouldn't even say his name you know
we've got a lot of these
so-called multi-millionaires so i've got
some good news for you
your fundraising's about to go through
the
awesome you know you can have them on
the show and and they're going to come
support you where can where can people
find you
i treat early.org treat
early.org that's the cetf fund 501c3
uh non-profit and you're guaranteeing
are you sure you want to make that
guarantee
absolutely why are you why why why okay
let me let me
let's see i'm so confident that we're
that you know we're
that we're gonna find something how can
you be this confident what
okay so you talk to these covet experts
and you say what's the most promising
you just asked about covet 19 what would
you take basically
if you got coveted tomorrow what did
these people say and what
are you looking into that corresponds
with that well tomorrow
um i'll probably take a combination
of a couple of drugs one i can't talk
about um
the other one would be chemostat so what
i did is when
early early on i talked to they're about
20 coronavirus experts in the entire
world
okay so these are people whose only life
is coronavirus and that's what i mean by
coronavirus experts so
you know they're just studying
coronavirus they're only like 20 in the
world so
i was able to talk to about eight of
them and i surveyed them and i said so
you know what are the top
you know if you were to get coronavirus
yourself what would you take
because i don't want to know what trump
would take i want to know what the
coronavirus experts would take
um you know i'm a little bit strange you
know i go after
science and scientists right rather than
um you know the the leader um
and and so so the the result of that
survey was the number one thing was
remdissevere that they were trying to
get
him to severe uh early and that that's
hard to do because the eua
the emergency use authorization only
allows you to
take get rim to severe if you're
hospitalized so it's too late
um so that would be the the first drug
people would take because it's proven
um if you give them to severe early in
monkeys they basically they have a good
time
they don't get sick so we know if you
give it very early
you know and this was in i think it was
uh
48 hours after infection they they
injected them nih did this study
they injected the monkeys um you know
versus uh placebo
and they found that yeah the monkeys
that they gave the virus to all got sick
and the monkeys that they
injected you know all had a nice time
wow
so we know remdisservier if it's given
early works
so that was the number one response was
remdissevier
the number two was camistad and camistad
is an approved drug
in japan and denmark most people heard
of that i've never heard of camastad
before talking to you
what is it what is it it's uh i'll i'll
show you here let's see i have a stash
of it
let's see
steve does it occur to you that you're
kind of the quintessential eccentric
millionaire you know who's made your
fortune and now you're kind of just like
you know like doing all these crazy
things yeah so
so anyway is that a japanese stash
yeah i have a stash of it
so um this is what it looks like
and uh and you can get it um
you know so i got this from from someone
in the u.s
it's not uh technically you can't import
it
but if you're able to get it into the
country uh
you can't arrest me for having it um
so fair enough i have a stash of it it's
it's called the tempus ii
uh it one of the the
uh enzymes that the virus uses to
replicate is
known as tempress two and so if you
inhibit
that enzyme from being produced the
virus basically can't split because the
virus
essentially needs help um because it's
your viru the virus is sort of like this
a thing that's outside of the normal
good stuff right and so it uses
different mechanisms to
uh to replicate and so one of the the
enzymes that it needs
is this thing called tempus 2. and the
canistet is a tempus 2 inhibitor
and so it inhibits the virus from
replicating and we have
anecdotal data um from
the studies that we're funding that it's
game changing
so look it's it's not going to hurt
and there there have been no adverse um
reactions so you know i sound a little
bit like donald trump here and saying
well it can't hurt
you know but in this case um this uh
proper dosages you're taking it at
proper doses dosages
and the side effect profile is you know
so
super mild um in terms of
and in fact the fda in our study
authorized us to increase the dose
of this uh drug and
so yeah this is a um
it you know there are some benefits to
to uh
you know doing this research but we
can't necessarily advise people do this
uh because we don't have the studies to
back it up
and so these studies are ongoing in the
us
and in denmark and we're the we are the
only funders
you know there were the the major
funders of of i should say the major
funders of of this research by far
um and that's that's that's another
criminal thing like you go
to the world's top people in coronavirus
they say other than um remdi severe
we should be looking at kamistad okay so
name
one kamistat trial in the u.s that's not
funded by us
you can't um so again this is like
okay i'm making a difference yeah no
it's definitely sounds too incredible to
be true
it does sound incredible let me tell you
why he sounds incredible because it
sounds like this hey i'm gonna make you
one percent
uh you know a day no no no no it does no
it doesn't sound like that
steve because you've you founded seven
legitimate companies
you've you know you're not just some
right yeah i mean you can go onto the
website and
you know you can go see it all but but
here's the thing right now what is
it by going to corona virus experts and
ask them let me tell you the same thing
i'll tell you what i'll tell you what's
incredible but nobody's listening to the
scientist
what's incredible is that there seem to
be so many smart people but it's
so laser focused on this like
vaccine or bust yeah and there's no
thought about
antivirals and i don't understand
because you know i did a whole piece on
coffee break of why we need to be
looking at antivirals and i went into
the whole problems with
you know vaccines including like just a
bunch of logistical issues obviously the
time
you rightfully point out that people are
less happy than ever to take a vaccine
in the first place
so there's so many reasons that vaccines
cannot be our only
it's got to be one of the tools in the
belt but it's just not the only tool oh
sure
yeah yeah yeah i mean the the the
off-the-shelf these repurposed drugs are
like
oh you got a fire on your your your
stove right now you know the the kitchen
pan just caught on fire
and there's a fire extinguisher there
that's sitting on the wall
well come on you should go and grab for
the fire extinguisher
and see is there anything left in it and
see if you can extinguish the fire
and if if not then you should go and
take your glass and a bucket of water
and see if you can take the bucket of
water or or you know baking soda or
whatever
and put it on the fire these are you
know sort of repurposing water and
repurposing baking soda and so forth to
stop the fire
before you call the fire department
instead it seems like
all we've done is just call the fire
department now we're just all waiting at
our houses for them to get
exactly yeah and in fact when you get
coveted the advice is
hey stay home but if you have breathing
problems come to the hospital
it ought to be the advice that everybody
should be getting
is enroll in a clinical trial if you got
coveted in your pcr
positive you should enroll in a clinical
trial on these
outpatient drugs because this is the way
we are going to find and prove
that these drugs work and no health
official
in the entire world as far as i know
i've never heard
any health official i've never heard
trump i've never heard
anybody say that hey if you get if you
if you're pcr positive
please enroll in a clinical trial
in your area and if it takes you two
miles to
or sorry it takes you two hours to drive
to the clinical trial to do it
do it please and do it for america
because
we need anyone who's got covid
to enroll in these trials because these
trials these outpatient trials
testing these drugs are starved
for patients how is that possible this
is a pandemic
theoretically there should never be a
better time
to be running a coronavirus trial you
that's what you would think so let me
give you
an example so interferon lambda so this
is
one of the the repurposed drugs that we
think is very promising
we got a call from mount sinai
saying hey we want to try this in
admitted patients and we're going like
no no no you should be giving it in
our patients treated early so now
they're already doing the outpatient
trial at stanford
we think it's also going to be useful
for inpatient so we said
yeah okay so they said rush us the money
so we got we rushed them 400 000
you know i tapped into my friends i said
you know this is
perfect you know these guys are in
ground zero
they're in new york city right you know
ground
zero this is mount sinai this is like
you know one of the biggest hospitals
overflowing with clinical trial patients
yeah so
guess how many patients it started uh
the trial started a couple of months ago
guess how many patients have enrolled
i don't know like five thousand
like zero
zero like zero why
like zero because no one knows or what
no they all know
they're they check into the hospital
they have to be given the standard
of care which is remdissevere and so
forth and so they're only they're only
so many people who can get rem dissevere
and then they have to agree to enroll in
the trial
and no one knows that nobody has nobody
has met the
the you know that criteria yet it's zero
it's it's mind-blowing
you know we have this it's killing
thousands of people
a day and we enroll zero in a trial of a
drug
for hospitalized patients that could
save their lives around zero ground zero
at ground
zero and to be clear most of these
clinical trials
they're not just for everyone listening
at home i think some people think
clinical trials
by the way you know this is it's it's
truth is stranger than fiction
this is not like people are just shoving
some random serum into you
these are drugs that have been studied
extensively by
experts this interfering lambda has been
given to people
for over a year it's been given to
thousands of people over a year with
no ill effects and all we're talking
about is one shot one shot that takes
five seconds would you do it one shot
and you have the chance to basically
save your life
change save your life and you'll save
other people's lives as well
enlightened self-interest yeah one shot
if this is inexplicable to me it is
strange well
i think part of it is the words not out
about
clinical trials and i think that's one
thing that i really appreciate you
talking about i mean
that's ends up that ended up being what
saved your life even
right back in the day when you had uh
walden strums or
again i'm gonna butcher it but uh you
enrolled
me on an email yeah didn't you enroll in
a clinical trial that saved
your life well yeah i mean i i i took
drugs that were basically uh only
available
under uh a clinical trial one at the
time that i took them
and so now i'm on a brute nib which
isn't a which is an approved drug but it
only became an approved drug because
enough people enrolled in the clinical
trial and so that it
that it got the fda approval now i would
expect that a lot of this
is welcome to the ears of people who are
what do you call it uh
vaccine hesitant is i think what they uh
are referred to as with people who don't
want to take vaccines because
look everything that steve's talking
about here guys most of them are drugs
they're antivirals i mean they're not
they're not sticking you with a vaccine
so those people should be celebrating
public health officials everywhere
should be celebrating because they can
deal with people they have a treatment
option for people who don't want to take
back right
and you know there's no funding i've
gotten zero funding from any government
state government federal government any
government even from a foreign country
you know we'd be happy to take money
from
i've gotten zero right and so we're
talking about something that has
cute but trillions of dollars of
economic downside
impact and yet i get zero
for the fastest most effective and only
20 million dollars i'm not asking for
the world here i'm asking for
steve
uh yeah yeah 20 million dollars is a lot
of money let's be clear
well no in the grand scheme of things
right when you're talking about writing
five trillion dollar stimulus checks 20
million dollars is a drop in the bucket
now have you ever thought if you're in
the state of california 20 million
dollars is dropping the bucket
now there is a saying that why do it
with your own money when you could do it
with someone else's but have you ever
thought of just like
ponying up the money and just being like
screw it for the good of humanity
yeah i've uh believe me i've i've i've
considered that but it's like
come on why should i be the only one in
the world there's
you know we got it i mean i put a
million dollars of my own money into
this
i'm glad you said that because i i want
to be clear that you have skin in the
game
yeah and jeff skull jeff skull is the
only
other millionaire or in this case he's a
billionaire
he's the only billionaire who's matched
it he's the only
other guy in the entire world
who has given us a million dollar check
the only guy jeff skull do you have any
other big names sort of in that uh
funding elon musk gave uh a substantial
amount and
and uh will probably give more uh his
foundation uh gave vin
vint cerf gave um some money jim
schwartz
um you know he's the founder of excel
you know of course
um you know you've got you've got big
donors on this list why can't
it's it's weird it seems like some
really smart people see you as like a
guy to
invest in uh it seems strange that you
okay it doesn't make any sense it
doesn't make i like keep coming back to
this thing if like it doesn't make any
sense
that we are putting so many eggs in this
vaccine basket which is
far off when we haven't done the due
diligence of sort of what you said which
is like
so first the fire extinguisher you know
it's like on your checklist
check hey do you have something on the
shelf that works let me oh i got
i only got eight things you know we've
only identified
eight things that need that should be
tested that need to be tested
it takes 20 million dollars to test
those
why isn't there a national priority
to test those eight things and instead
there's no focus on it and so
these things are just taking forever and
they're getting stuck in
in institutional politics and these
studies that
should have gone at full speed months
ago
are only getting started now you'd be
appalled
if you knew the enrollment numbers on
how low the enrollment numbers
are in these trials that have been
started interesting uh
let me ask you this so there's also
another drug you're pretty excited about
which is gs44 that's not the full name
there's a much more
even more boring name out there i'm
gonna give you guys
zero points for the name although i
don't think you named it but it's
basically
similar to rim deserves like sort of a
cousin of rim deserver
but there's differences that make it
a much more appealing option can you
talk a little bit about
about that sure so in the proc so
it turns out that it's it's like a
six-month process to make rem dissevere
so you make this drug first called
gs441524
and that's pretty easy to make and
um and it's very cheap to make and then
you go through a bunch of process steps
and six months later out pops a little
bit of remdi severe
so gs44 is a precursor to rim desktops
in the synthesis
it's in the synthesis it's in the
synthesis step so it's it's made
and in fact they had to get all sorts of
safety approvals for gs44 because
when you inject rem to severe it turns
into gs44 after you've injected it
into people and so we slowly thought hmm
huh that's interesting yeah maybe it's
well it turns out that cats
have been cured from coronavirus for
years
not for years but for you know for like
over a year
um uh there's this feline version of
coronavirus it's called
fil and so gs441524
it has been used to cure cats of
coronavirus
now that doesn't mean it'll cure
starscope too though but it
doesn't mean that it cures it in people
but
interesting interesting so
we looked at all the data and basically
said look you know this looks
really really promising this is cheaper
to produce it's safer
it's easy to give to people because you
give to people orally
you don't have to inject it like remdi
severe so
you can give to this to people as a pill
when they first get the disease and it's
basically an antiviral that hooks on
and it makes it so that the virus thinks
this is the legitimate stuff but it
basically comes up the works
and we think this is going to be like
the killer drug for it but we have to go
through all the steps to prove it
and i i mean i i think you absolutely
should where are you guys with that work
um so we're doing the uh basically the
animal research and the safety research
to prove that
um that it's safe and that it works and
that it's get
that it gets absorbed so we've done uh
research in that
in primates to to show that if you give
it orally
that um it comes out in the urine and so
that means it's systemically
absorbed it's getting into the
bloodstream we have to to prove that we
can get it
at sufficiently high um uh high dose
uh to be effective um but the nih has uh
expressed interest in um in this so this
is good
you know we've attacked we've attracted
their attention and uh they're taking it
very seriously
and uh gilead to their credit is being
cooperative um
uh with this and giving us the uh the
necessary approvals to
to take the experiments to the next step
that's awesome now do they own
gs44 is that like one of their patents
um rem disavir does yeah
no no they own rim deserve but they
don't own jesus yeah no they
yeah they own the precursor as well okay
i got it i got it i got it so but
they're but they're being cooperative
which is obviously very good
let me ask you where do you see this
going because
there sort of are um a number
of things that could obviously happen
are you still fundraising for cetf
you are right absolutely um i'm done
i'm done when we raised 20 million
because they don't need to raise any
more than that we you know
we'll test everything that's on the
shelf i mean that's never
other things that are they're gonna
that'll pop out um
but you know my goal was just to say
look you know we should be testing
everything that's basically out there
right now
let's go do that and let's see if
there's a signal and
i think the chances are pretty good that
uh that of the eight uh
uh approved experiments that at least
four of them will will yield something
that's that's fairly significant
you know for anywhere from 100 effective
to 75 percent effective and
for some even you know a bit less but
um taking together you know a
combination of these things so we're
trying to find the signal and
you know we're kind of like a seed stage
venture capitalist where
we find the signal and then we give it
to the nih and
and so forth to uh uh to go and uh and
amplify that signal
right it's just like you know seat stage
versus late stage venture capital
right the late stage venture capitalists
need the seed stage guys because you
know we're nimble and fast and
we look at all sorts of things and we
waste some money
um but in this case we've got you know
super high track record of the
of the four that we're investigating
we've got you know signals and basically
all four
that's incredible now you seem like also
a bit of an iconoclast in that you
have some definite criticisms of the
larger sort of bureaucratic
um health organizations as being
wasteful
now let me ask you this what do you
do you think that's their role
ultimately though is sort of as a late
stage
venture capitalism and we've just been
kind of looking at them for the solution
to every problem rather than at a select
number of problems that they are good at
um
or what do you think our mistake has
been here because it seems to be you're
saying
we've just mismanaged our resources in
this crisis we have it obviously there's
a lot of money in covet 19 but
it's just being put towards the wrong
uses is what you're saying
you know governments are really good at
um
at doing certain things
but responding quickly in a pandemic is
not something necessarily that they were
you know sort of set up to do
but the fda to its credit i mean i got
to give the fda and the nih a lot of
credit i mean i have a
lot of respect for um for those guys and
you know i see some of the
correspondence uh that that's happening
and
um couldn't be more appreciative of the
people who work at at
nih um and uh uh
and and the fda on this you know but
this is a
uh uh a really unexpected thing like the
fda normally moves really really slowly
and to their credit they've approved
things um very very quickly you know in
some cases maybe
stuff that they shouldn't have um but
um you know they're they're they're
taking action
and i think that that's um that's really
good um
because inaction is a form of action in
this case in the pandemic where people
are dying inaction and just failing to
approve
new drugs is its own type of problem
yeah right so so it's good that um
that this is happening um so
i'm i'm really uh i'm really pleased
that that it's not being gummed up
but on the other hand as far as funding
for researchers
goes that has been kind of a disaster
because
i've talked to researchers who have
grants
for like aids for example and and who
applied
for a uh so they could repurpose their
grant money on kovid
and basically were turned down on that
and so that's
problematic as to why that is like why
why don't we give them you know like
blanket approval or like um
you know those are virologists working
on one type of
is trying to work on another class of
virus yeah
exactly yeah i mean they should be able
to to just repurpose the funds
and uh and that's not happening
so uh that's a little bit
um that was yeah i'm not not too happy
about that
well said well steve i love your
approach to things i mean i do
appreciate
sort of you're approaching this and
maybe the most intelligent way that i've
heard
which is that you're not going for
obviously late stage therapeutics or
you're going for early stage
therapeutics
which may not get as many headlines but
i think is a far more
effective way um to go about it
now sort of as a a last thing i mean
let's just remind everyone
if you want to donate if you're a
multi-millionaire if you got some if you
got some cash in the bank
if you're one of these gurus out there
who's got a ton of money you've taken
from a bunch of poor people
and you want to put it to a good place
go to treat or you're making one percent
you're making one percent a day that's
right you can go and treat early drugs
trading just 30 minutes a day
street early daughter i'm trying to
shout out your fun treat early.org
um to go donate now steve let's just
wrap this up by talking a bit about some
again our mutual passion the one thing
we have in common
uh scams
if you look at the world today did you
expect that there would still be this
many
scams out there taking advantage of
people and as someone who's
actually made successful exits in
multiple
multiple countries excuse me companies
um
what would you say to entrepreneurs to
avoid those really common pitfalls of
too good to be true and
things like that what do you think
helped you uh
okay so does it surprise me that there
are all these scams out there
no in the end and in fact during a
pandemic
it actually i think increases um yeah
and i think and you ran out you did a
nice piece on that you know showing that
the scum of the scum you know they're
they're taking advantage of people
who are in desperate straits and and
are looking for something and you know
you're they're preying on these people
who are desperate right because they've
been
impacted um from uh
from the from covet and and they're
they're more susceptible
now right to oh my gosh here's a
get-rich-quick thing i can get
i can get out of this and what happens
is of course the opposite where they get
driven deeper by people who are you know
have just no compassion
at all right i mean it's it's it's
really
bringing out the worst of the worst
so yeah it does so it doesn't surprise
me there
there are people who do this um
yeah um and then your other question
uh is the uh uh advice
uh uh for people you know so you know
the investing advice is actually
uh to ignore you know if you think about
who the most successful investors are
right the warren buffett's and so forth
if you're getting 20 a year return
you need to like pat yourself on the
back to say
man you are doing better than anybody
else in the world so anybody who's
promising you
one percent a day and 99
or 95 of our trades are profitable
you know you you you know there's this
guy
carl dom um who's got a website and he
uh subscribes to these things and says
yeah he subscribed to
so and so and so you know uh markay
latimer or whatever her name is you know
and i subscribe to
what and he'll go through and he'll tell
you so you don't have to spend the money
right because he spent the money he
enrolled in the course and he'll tell
you
and he'll tell you that these trades
that they
claim you know are 95 profit
like none of them are profitable yeah
and in fact
you would think okay then this is
perfect
right because if this guy you know you
go on trustpilot
and you see the reviews right i mean i i
encourage anybody who's
who's going to do any of this to look at
the negative reviews
on trustpilot and i'm not the positive
reviews because those are
generally fake but you look at the
negative reviews
and read them on trustpilot and then you
say oh my gosh
this guy is like a hundred percent wrong
all the time
so i should subscribe to his service and
actually do the opposite
but that won't work either you know
so there isn't
there isn't these things just don't work
they're just scams to get people's money
and you're better off doing the time and
trusted thing like
invest in an index and invest in the s p
index invested in the nasdaq
index or whatever i mean that's a pretty
good
you know if you just invested in nasdaq
over 11 years you'd have 21
return brainless how are you going to
beat that
yeah well uh many people claim they can
but there were very few people who
actually but look
nobody's got the 11 year history that's
right that's what i always say because
people come to me they go well stephen
i've got 50
over two months and i always say come
back to me in 10 years and show me your
average return
and then we'll talk because all these
people claiming they made 100 in two
months i don't care what you made in two
months or five months or six months
i care what you made over 10 years
that's exactly right i mean you're
you're dead on the money um
lastly do you think there's been been a
bit of
too much
lionization of entrepreneurship like
there's this
thing now where so many of my friends
none of them respect having a
nine-to-five job anymore there's almost
no respect for a nine-to-five job
everyone thinks that you got to go out
and be the next elon musk you gotta
unless
or die trying or go broke trying
i'm kind of of the old school where i
mean it's funny because
actually i am you know kind of i've just
gone off and done my own thing
but i have a lot of respect and i think
there's a lot to be said about
nine to five jobs as being a good choice
for most people almost by definition not
all of us can be founders
what would you say to that as a founder
who's been wildly successful
um the the beauty of a nine to five job
is that it's a consistent uh positive
income which is something that you're
not going to get from trading
and invest but but you know you should
you should have a combination of
active stuff um where you have it have a
job and and if you get to the point in
your life where you're ready to start a
company
then you can you know up the level of
that
um and you know you've earned the right
to be able to
you know you take you you've earned you
earn your 40
you know in my case i earned like 40 000
you know i saved away because i was
frugal
and i took my um uh
my salary saved away forty thousand
dollars
uh out of that salary and i use that to
risk it
on starting my own company and
in that case then i can multiply those
returns
and so it's just like you know other so
some people you know have a nine-to-five
job and then they they quit that and
they
they start youtube channels and they can
make an income
off of that and some of them can do
really really well
but they take a risk in doing that and
it's you know much tougher to do now
because there's so much competition
than it was earlier but if you have
really good content and you promote it
right and you have good
high production values and so forth uh
you can do really well
but there is no like shortcut you know
to
like hey you know if i just knew this i
can relax and i can spend an hour a day
um on this um you you have to earn your
way
uh to it and there aren't any shortcuts
in life
um and you're hearing this guys
not for me you're hearing this from a
guy who's worth a lot more
than you okay because all these guys
that go listen to me i'm a millionaire
you know elon musk for example i mean
here's a guy
who's um you know who took some big
risks you know he started tesla
and at um i had lunch with him uh one
time and
um it was great it was private lunch i
mean i
i i emailed and asked him for a for
lunch he was kind enough to i mean i
argue had to argue my way in but
he was kind enough to uh we had a nice
little lunch in his office
at tessa and he told me the story that
there was a point to tesla
where there were they needed to raise
money and one of the
one of their investors uh blocked it and
and he said this made no sense like we
were trying to save the company and why
would an investor block it it wasn't in
the
investor's self-interest and normally
you think investors
um always operate in their own
self-interest right this guy blocked it
and tesla almost went under
because of this one investor and elon
would have lost
like everything and so these people take
big big risks so he's like one step away
from losing
everything that's what you're telling me
yeah and
the total history of tesla could have
been entirely different almost
just off of this one incident and he was
able to pull a rabbit out of the hat on
this one
wow yeah wow true story
that's absolutely incredible and that
yeah the history books would have a
whole different story
it'd be the guy who flew too close to
the side he
he took a big loss and now you never
hear from him again that's
that's amazing that's an amazing story
um
wow well steve i want to be respectful
of your time you have a lot to get to
we're already running a little bit over
what i promised you
um so thank you sure my pleasure thanks
for coming on the show
and um yeah a pleasure yeah
guys treat early.org treat early.org
thank you for watching
[Music]
burn through thanks plastic stacks
[Music]
a mouthful of money
[Music]
comes along